so hello everybody i'm here with
benedict and talia sheehan
you have probably seen them on my
channel before
and so benedict is a composer and talia
is a
choir conductor they are at saint econ
seminary they they direct the choir
there
but benedict is also a composer and
recently in the past few years he has
been kind of this
you know this crazy ascending uh moment
and he is now nominated for grammy for
his uh
for his liturgy and i just wanted to
talk about it because i've been really
excited to follow him
social media to see all the attention
that his work is getting so i'm really
looking forward to hearing about how he
is able to be a liturgical composer in
the contemporary world
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
so benedict please tell us a little bit
about what's going on with your
liturgy i mean i think it's not even
just your literacy or all the other
things
that are yeah so uh just to be
just to be clear it's it's actually not
my
liturgy that i'm nominated for right now
oh okay
so uh but but it's actually for my work
as a
as a chorus master or a choral a choral
preparer for the cas for the kastowski
requiem recording that just came out at
the end of
august my liturgy got released
in october which means it's in the next
it's in
the next year's round for the grammys so
it's too early
to know about that one but i'm hopeful i
mean it's it there's it's gotten great
reviews and it's um it's also like
number one on the classical charts for
it was number yeah it debuted number two
on the
billboard um which was great i mean
that's pretty pretty awesome for a thing
that is produced by
you know more or less by saying by
saying
take guns to dairy we we haven't
even had ever enjoyed that kind of
spotlight so um it's pretty awesome
yeah well to me it's like there's a it's
a testimony to some of the things that
i've been thinking about or i
i would set the testimony to my own
journey too or to other people that we
know like andrew
uh and other i would say people who are
really striving for excellence
and have felt like the contemporary art
scene
is stale and so trying to revivify
traditional form but not in a just not
in a
i would say not in a kind of nostalgic
desire to crack
the past but in this alive this form
that's alive and that is connecting to a
real community
yeah that's exactly exactly the way i
would put it wouldn't you agree
yeah it's born out of the sort of you
know
it's born out of the daily life but
worship
is here at this place at this monastery
and partly it's it was actually that
that work the work of oh gracious excuse
me oh we're gonna have to edit that out
we actually still have a well we
actually still have a funnel
find for no earthly reason that i can
come up with no reason at all yeah but i
think it's just nostalgia
actually there needs to be some physical
connection
even though my wife refuses to have a
cell phone and so we have a landline
and uh it's the main phone for our house
and she just refuses
to have a cell phone which i admire her
greatly because i
i refuse for like i didn't have a cell
phone until about
2017 and uh wow and then
but then i was just forced by everything
to get one and since yeah
completely addicted so yeah which i like
it's a good tool it's just the tool
starts using us after a while
but uh the yeah so i mean okay
you're saying that it was born out of
the the prayer life and the worship life
of the monastery
yeah and and you know to to a great
extent the you know so
there has to be context for artists and
and the more
immediate the context is the more it's
grounded in
um in in a a daily experience kind of
the more validated the art is
and that's definitely what's happened
here at saint economics because you know
we have the
privilege it's also a burden to a
certain extent but the privilege
of the worship being exclusively vocal
and exclusively almost exclusive
exclusively coral and exclusively
unaccompanied
which puts an artistic constraint on
what we do
in a way that necessitates creativity
and
you know if you have to do it every
second every single day that's even
that's even more interesting you will go
insane
if you aren't doing something creative
so that the abbot here father sergius is
is hugely supportive of
the work to um you know to create
beautiful uh worship singing because
a it's just like as frequently as they
have to do it and they have to endure
the doing of it like it had it had
better not be awful like please let's
fix
problems let's not just let problems
sort of sit we gotta
do something about this but then also to
kind of cultivate a vision
and and that's really what what to say
it comes from the life here at the
monastery it really is it really is that
it's born out of that
that vision for what it could be yeah
right and
so and so in part i mean so so the the
the the liturgy that i composed and that
we recorded you know that's not the kind
of
music or this gale of
music that we could sing every day
church like to be clear that this is not
every day
kind of you know like you you get up
it's
6 00 a.m and you go and sing the liturgy
it's not that
thank goodness yes um you know so it's
like if
if you're you know it's like the
difference between
you know your kind of work outfit that
you go to do
carpentry and and you know a
a black tie you know a black tie
outfit or a ball get down or something
like that
but i do think these things are are very
they're very integrally connected
because
you have to be able to to
to look up words and to look outwards
and to see
you know we we say that the liturgy is
an i i kind of the kingdom of
god a lot of the time it doesn't feel
like the
kingdom of god at all but but it's okay
because in a sense like every now and
then you might get it you might get an
inkling of that and um
and that and that little glimpse is
enough to sustain everything else that
you do
and to inspire everything else that you
do
um so i kind of see the the the
work of trying to create like new great
works that arise out of the or out of
the orthodox
um con text of worship
but are not just aimed at at it
um is is part of in trying to inspire
a new a a new uh
how can i say it a new school of art a
new
a new
a new reason to put it to put energy and
res
sources into to this
um that's what the saint evan choir was
now and this performance of the
gustalsky rapidium because that's
obviously not a liturgical work
and not only is it not a liturgical work
it incorporates
like it it's it's a it's an almost an
international work
it has custody envisioned it as being
representative of
of the international um you know uh
the allies of the allies in world war
one and so he
he envisioned it that way and then the
performance of it almost winds up being
like
uh a work of diplomacy because the
forces are so huge there were
three three ensembles four four four
three choirs and four choirs and an
orchestra
that went into doing this and it really
it felt like
talking about symphony you know like it
felt like
multiple levels of reality coming
together to do a thing all to the same
purpose
and then the you know and then the
pieces
and then the pieces itself
it weaves together
religious music from the traditions of
all the allies so there's
there's there's there there's repression
or there's a
russian orthodox chant but there's um
but
but there's gory enchant and there's and
there and then there's an episcopal
um he came to tunes and american hymns
but they're about there but there's also
there there's also a japanese uh is
like like it was a shinto
melody in there and there's and there
and there's an indian um
vedic here him but
the idea being that that through this
kind of expression of
honoring the dead through through stone
it brings together all the nations of
the
world into this one single
sound um and it's a beautiful beautiful
image and it's a beautiful piece of
music so that that's that i
i i see that
that all of that is connected
to this kind of routine work of trying
to be in church all the time
um the wealth that we take and we offer
as worship is
is necessarily created outside of the
worship the
economy that sustains the church is not
and it's it's not a
closed system so we have to be creating
we have to be creating wealth outside of
worship
in order to enrich worship yeah and i
think that you're
one of the things that kind of hits me
as i'm listening to speak is
one of the strength of the way that the
orthodox will
envision reality and to envision it in
terms of a hierarchy instead of
envisioning it in terms of opposites or
in terms of this is inside this is
outside you know this is good this is
bad
but rather seeing it as this outflowing
of a hierarchy and so when you talked
about
the idea that let's say you try to aim
with your
your own composition to something which
in a way
is not accessible to the everyday choir
of every church
but nonetheless becomes an aim and
that's what hierarchy does is that
you can have an aim and then the fact
that you don't reach that aim doesn't
mean that you're going to hell
it just means that you're that you're
moving that everything is moving and
kind of
uh in this discussion with the higher
things and
trying to embody them as much as
possible in the moment that we're living
today
and understanding that we fail all the
time and that we're always
kind of not reaching that ideal and so i
think there's something very powerful
about what you said
and and talia which you talked about the
idea of an economy which is outside the
church
i think that that's that's really very a
very powerful way of understanding it
which is that
in a way liturgical music doesn't have
the
it doesn't have the symphonic aspect
like you said that something which is
outside the church could have but it's
fed by
the simpler patterns that we or the more
pure patterns that we find in liturgy
or that we find even in iconography can
then boil over
and how funny is that it will act
sometimes look like the outside works
are more complex or more subtle or all
of these things you know like right
novel obviously it's more subtle and
more complex
than the the liturgical uh pattern
but the liturgical pattern has this
purity which then kind of
unfolds and kind of sprinkle down into
all these other works
that's a really beautiful way to yeah
that's a beautiful way to put
quite that sorry we have we have a
that's
okay we have
the real
because i do this every day i have a
door that closes
and everybody knows in the house well we
do too but it's we
but it's not well lit the room that we
we wanted to use it's all right we have
we have a lot of
kids in a small in a small space so it's
just part of the
it's part of the for it's part of the
work of it
but i i love this idea of identifying
identifying
patterns um you know because we we have
this
idea some times that like that that the
patterns that you see in
church art are somehow
are somehow the origin of all the other
patterns that you see
in in art but i actually tend to see
them as kind of
the as kind of the dis
down of them they're they're not the
origin
um church art and the life
of the church of the church draws on
everything
it borrows from everything um well good
way to understand it i would say is the
difference between
let's say you could say that it's it's
the if they're the origin in the sense
that they're closer to the source or the
but they're also not the origin in terms
of body the body comes from the outside
right
right out of the body christian
iconography
is based on roman art they took all the
roman tropes of art
and then they like you said exactly
distilled them
removed some things adjusted some things
and then kind of push them towards
something
uh push them towards a very pure
language compared to the very sensual
and and uh you know
chaotic language of late roman art
yeah so the quote i guess the
question has always been for us how to
feed this
because i we we both feel that we're in
a time
right now where where church art has
become
really has become rather poor
in terms of both the understanding of it
and more importantly the practice
of it and i think we see it the most
clearly at least
where else we see it the most clearly in
how people
how people sing in church and and kind
of the energy of
the difficulty the difficulty with how
you sing in church is that you have to
do it over and over and over again right
you can't just like
to do it and then and then it's all done
it's like every time you go to
church you have to sing again and ever
and every
minute that you're in church you have to
you have to keep
that's on the right take like that's a
good take that's not how it works in
church right
yeah right right so so
in in a way tr the this is
this is staining of music in the
church is the work of sustaining the
people and the work of sustaining
their abilities the work of sustaining
their their
their just their ability to be there
um and and and unfortunately sustaining
their interests
they're right exactly sustaining their
interests which is to a great extent i
think
why a lot of uh a lot of church singing
is suffering from a lack of talent um
because
without a sort of without something of a
transcendent vision
that kind of gives
gives direction to the everyday task
of of you know the the
the clothes that you wear to go do
carpentry um
then it it becomes very drying
and so um you know in in
in education uh in teaching people
i i like to call it an extended purpose
it's like that thing that everybody
focuses
their energy on that's a that's a sort
of
an intermediate goal it's not it's not
the next life
you know it's not paradise some are too
far away that's that yeah
you can't you can't effectively work
towards that on an everyday level you
have to have an intermediate goal and i
think to a great extent we use pasca as
that intermediate goal
but there also has to be artistic
intermediate goals
and without working to kind of find that
for your
average everyday um you know person
participating in worship
it's really hard to maintain the dryness
of of the routine
and so i mean i'm curious because i
don't i've confessed this to you guys
into
people who watch my videos before that i
don't understand music but
uh my so i'm curious so when you write
let's say you wrote
the liturgy so i listened i listened to
the liturgy and i i
have to admit that i did find it i was
trying to to be
as aware as possible and i did what i
found like my experience of it was it
kept moving me from
something from someone who who has been
to church for for several years now
uh something familiar and then kind of
moving me into an unfamiliar space and
then kind of bringing me back into a
familiar space
and i kept feeling this this tug where
all of a sudden i'm like okay
i know where i am and then all of a
sudden i'm not so sure anymore but then
there's a little something that reminds
me
uh you know it's as if i didn't think i
had a
i didn't think i had a musical
vocabulary if it means to be in church
but i could kind of feel that happening
to me
if i would listen to it so i don't know
if that's really i don't know if i'm
onto something i have no idea well
that's kind of the experience of
development in music there's always an
establishment of a baseline and that
baseline is kind of like a
a contract between the listener and the
performer or the composer
depending on how you scale the
relationship and
and so you know where you're starting
from and then there has to be a sort of
hero's journey and that in musical terms
that's called
development um and that might be you
know chord changes it might be texture
changes but there's
always there's always some sort of
of movement away from the initial
stability and this is of course the
monomyth and
there's ways of interpreting music
according to this structure that are
pretty pretty widely used but
that sense of i'm here now i've moved
away
and it's uncertain and it's unstable but
then it gets resolved again
is absolutely right that's a theme that
you that it
goes through all of music um
on many levels of resolution right
exactly i mean that the whole idea of
of the sonata form which is where all
the great
pennies of the past
relied on the idea of a b and then a
return of
a and um you know in some sense that's
like the history of
time the history of mankind it's you
know in in in the
repression world view of beginning
from places to uh
that is yet incomplete it's not it's not
fully
for formed it's naive it's
young and then it has to fall
or depart or to go out it has to leave
in
some way and experience trial
and er and adversity and
and ch change and growth and and
and evolution and then at some po
point it then and then it returns
to that place of stability but it's by
but it's been made
new it's transformed it's been it's been
it's mature um you know so
so that's that's in a sense that's the
story of mankind
in in in our world view um
uh but and i think you know like you
think about like any pop song is in a
sense aba
it's like you know it begins with you
know production it builds to the bridge
and then you come back to the
beginning again and it's the most
satisfying thing to be
satisfied it's the three acts that's
that familiar content but with the
with the knowledge that you gained or
with the perspective that you gained
having traveled away from it
and that's why the hook brings you back
you know it's just like oh yes
so it's been i'm glad so anyway i'm glad
i'm glad to know that you're kind of
experiencing that on a route
level as you're as you're listening
because i
that means like okay that means i'm i'm
kind of on the right
it helps me know that i'm on the right
track
in some way because i mean i
know there's a kind of myth
i think that we have about about about
about composers that
you know and i think i think that com
composers very often tend to help
perpetuate this this
myth them them
themselves and which is that like
of course it was all my
of course i planned all this uh you know
but
really i would say i mean i don't know
what
goes through the mind of other composers
but but i
i susp the fact that a lot of us
don't really plan anything um i mean
we i mean there there there there's all
kinds of
techniques that you use to to kind of
organize
and to get things to get things to move
when they're
when they're kind of stopped up and um
and prompt or a prompt you know like our
autistic forms are are but they often
act as a good pro pro prompt
um but then but when you i
actually sit down to do the work of like
what is what is the next note what is
the next
sound no you don't know what's going to
come out
uh and and and so often then you look
then on the back and you're like oh
that's that's what i was trying to do
but you didn't know at the time yeah you
just kind of you did it
but it's just like you you and i'm sure
that
i i'm sure that there's an analog to
doing the
visual art for sure analog to doing
to writing stories or to telling stories
i always tell because people always ask
me
oh i wish i could use the symbolic stuff
you're talking about to write stories
and so there and i tell them
stop thinking about symbolism when
you're writing a story you have to
exactly
like think about symbolism before think
about symbolism after but don't do that
while you're writing your story
you're gonna not you won't be able to do
anything like just let it
go the hat let it happen and then after
that you can maybe edit it
and and maybe you know uh you can notice
what you're doing like you said and then
adjust some aspects which maybe aren't
totally in line with what it is you're
seeing that's happening
but don't while you're writing seriously
don't don't uh
don't do that yeah i know exactly
and so i have a i haven't
he had to learn to actually to
forcefully and it was an act of will
ignore the suggestion that arose to
to take that kind of a critical
perspective on his work as he was
working
yeah and and you know sometimes he tells
this this part isn't a secret that that
you know for a time he's a carpenter um
professionally and
and it was the it was the immediacy of
the
having to get the job done it was almost
the contractual obligation
and the fact that you know this was some
place somebody or something needed to
live
um and it just had to get done meant
that it was training and how to apply it
that
um how to quiet that sort of um
insecure voice um and and you know
that's kind of a procedural
um uh cognition right there's like
rational cognition and procedural
cognition your body just has to know to
do a thing in order for
you know it's almost like we have two
different brains the the part that
thinks and the part that that does
we're always trying to align them um so
you know you're doing
you're composing you're carving it's
like just let the doing part
do its thing and you'll find this
incredible
you know complexity and wonder it's like
trust the procedural brain
we have to train it some too but yeah
training happens by doing
it's like there's some things that
especially in carving for example there
are some things that i'm doing now that
i never thought
it's only when i now that i would take a
picture of an old carving and a new
carving and i realized oh
i'm doing this differently but i never
thought about it i didn't plan it out it
just
it's just as you're doing all of a
sudden like you said you
your body you're in this flow of making
and your body realizes that
if i do it this way it's better and it's
cleaner and it's nicer and it just
kind of happens and so for sure when i'm
carving i'm not thinking about
i'm not thinking about what i'm doing in
the same way that if i'm making a video
for example if i'm talking about a
subject
yeah that's why my brain is actually
free when i'm carving when i'm carving i
can listen to
i can listen to like seven hours of a
podcast
because it's there's like my body is
doing this but my mind is actually
quite quite available yeah well so this
is the
this is the the elephant of the rider
which would be an interesting thing
talked about but i interrupted you
so i don't um no i mean i had i guess i
have a big question
coming from someone who doesn't
understand music yeah
my my big question is so you so you
write let's say
this liturgy and
my question is what makes it a liturgy
i mean except for not just the words
obviously the words we know that that's
what
that's the obvious answer yeah but what
is it about let's say
the way that you approach the music
which makes it
uh a liturgical piece rather than just
something
that you hear on the radio or whatever
other type or another type of music that
that could be or dancing music or
whatever it is
that's a really really hard question
it's possibly a hugely subjective
question
yeah well i mean there are there are
certainly things that are not suggestive
like you know um
well i think that well i i i think the
words are in some way the most the most
the most obvious
answer like in the orthodox tradition
we you know over the over the last
couple millennia we
more or less arrived at at a point where
things like
words are kind of sentenced to
down so words and then perhaps except if
we want to translate
this well but translational plating is a
major issue right
yes and and then and then and then the
order in which
those words appear appear you know like
in a sense like when
what hypnography comes after
but that that has certainly been
things you know that that has been
subject to change in the
past but it hasn't changed a lot in the
last
i don't know 400 or 500
years um
uh but i guess it's this thing i i i
would say it would start from this thing
called
that we culture that we call
tradition but um which is the thing i'm
always
kind of trying to underst stand
what what what it is because
we we often we tend to use that
word to mean an old thing rather than a
new thing and i think that's not at all
what it
means um tradition is really a series of
new
things um it
it's it's it's
maybe a better word is life um
uh and and the way in which
life is always linear
um so like uh
dies a tree keeps on
growing and it keeps on producing new
branches and new leaves and new fruits
and the trunk grows
the tower every part of the tree grows
the
tree roots go deeper it produces new
trees
um and and but but all of that
growth is though it's in a sense omnidir
retrospective it's still always
it's a linear in some ways in some way
it's it's always
connected to what came before it it
proposed in secret in sequence
um so there's a continuity yeah there's
a continuity in uh
in terms of communal continuity that is
we're a part of the same community
and there's continuity in the sense of
continuation which is
that i take what those that are there
before have handed to me
and now i continue with that as a the
day
that's complicated by the strange
mobility that we have
as modern people and by being in the
united states
like okay so you and i jonathan were
both converts and that's the kind of
mobility that humans
really that was inconceivable to the
vast majority of humans through the vast
majority of human history like why would
you separate yourself from
your uh your identity from the network
that has actually
borne you and nurtured you and given you
any agency that you have
why would you willingly separate
yourself from that in order to
follow an individual conviction first of
all individuals weren't actually
permitted to do anything of the sort for
the vast majority you just die
like who are you gonna get food from
forget it right yeah
so we have this like weird privilege
that we can actually make these
decisions for ourselves but what that
means because we can make these
decisions for ourselves
and i personally firmly believe that
that would have been impossible without
christ
because it was christ that called us to
individual conscience
as opposed to group conscience and so
that's
like that was a little revolution in
humanity but
we have this weird thing now where we
bring
to as by just being plugged into this
suddenly we bring the the places we were
before
into the tradition which means that what
seemed like worship to people who knew
something other than orthodox worship
is now now it has to be listened to it
has to it has to actually be
somehow at least yeah yeah
and and now part of the church and that
life we can't just ignore that life and
and be
you know society for creative
anachronism and and
and try and maintain i
okay which i think is great i'm not
saying we're not saying anything bad
about these
yes yeah it's really a cool thing and
the church
sometimes does feel like yes it does but
you know what
frankly black tie is sca a little bit it
is too and
going to the opera is also s and if we
don't if we don't have those things
in our lives it yeah it's pretty awesome
but his voice as a composer is
necessarily
influenced by his experience in a
culture that is not exclusively
christian or exclusively orthodox
yeah i think that one of the things that
one of the ways of understanding it
in terms of the tree let's say is that
we have this strange situation
where let's say that the tradition the
tree of the orthodox tradition
is now been planted in the soil that it
doesn't know and now
all the nutrients that that are there
all the possibilities that are there
are not the usual nutrients and so it'll
cause a transformation in the tree but
there has to be a way for it to be
transformed so that we still recognize
the tree or else
then or else what or else why are we not
then why did we become orthodox in the
first place
because whatever
we just become presbyterian or just
become some some other
some other thing and so there's there's
i think like you said it's like as if
there's a more intense discussion
which is happening in america also
because of the mixture of different
ethnic groups
you know coming together in this strange
land of mixture
um so it's it's like an accelerated uh
it's like an accelerated laboratory
something which maybe of maybe
it would have happened over centuries
you know at the media places where
russia came in contact with other
cultures and georgians were
you know fighting with russians but also
in the same church and all this kind of
stuff that would
infiltrate and transform culture is
happening
in in like fast forward well as it as is
the rate of technological advancement
yeah so many things about like so many
things about
about our lives right now are so much
better and effective and
easier than they were 15 years ago yeah
you know and and that kind of innovation
comes from that's
happening all over the world and that's
happening all over the world
right and and that comes from the
uncomfortable
like the negotiation between conflicting
um conflicting forces
right and and i think the liturgy is
this in
incredible it's like it's some people
experience it as a war
i was just talking to one of the monks
who was like you know what the liturgy
is
it's it's fighting i experienced the
other in
the other players he did not mean like
you know like the idea of spiritual
world warfare and doing about it with
the t
demons which i think some people have
all kinds of weird
ideas about but no he's just like he's
like no no when i'm serving the choir is
the actual enemy
yeah you know fire is the enemy the
altar servers are the enemy
but it's like it's like a sport right
it's like a game
where it's our voluntary participation
in that conflict that actually creates
this thing that's like a positive some
game like it's
way more valuable than had we not
engaged in that conflict
yeah and that's that's tantalizing but
it's about it's about these things that
don't
in a sense go to get together and
then the work of trying to put them to
get to
to get together and what else is what
else is chris
even a
or the idea of god becoming men or the
uncreated
and the created i mean like things that
don't go together that don't belong to
to get together and yet somehow they
have to negotiate
and they have to come together to get to
get together the idea of
of love is exactly what
that's what that is it's it's
too in a sense mutually opposed or
realities having to to you to unite
um so and it's the pattern that it's
just the pattern of everything
i mean everything is like that and so
the
the let's say the distinction between
like you said a fight and a dance
if you watch two boxers you'll realize
how close
those two realities are yeah they're
coming into rhythm with the person that
in front of you they're trying to
understand where they're going where
what
anticipate their next movement all of
this is part of the
of how you you do engage in a fight uh
and then so hopefully
hopefully that that fight looks more
like a dance in the christian
in the in the christian world and say
but i can understand the analogy
perfectly
yeah well right and so in that that way
that's kind of to go back to what you
were asking at the at the
beginning of like how do i write a
liturgy what
what what is it that will that will
make it a liturgy um
uh i'm in a sense i'm doing battle with
with the tradition
as i've received it it's this
negotiation
yeah or just a straight up a battle
where it's like
i've received a thing it's like no this
is not going to work
for me or it's not going to work for us
but
i still understand you and respect you
so
i'm going to come up with a different
answer that i think you
will agr
that that you might agr agree with or
you might accept
um you know it's not like me trying to
assert my own in
individual quality it's this sense of
how do i unite myself to this the thing
that so often if you know is so what is
seems so alien and so and
so other and so remote it's like the act
of
of jacob having to to fight with the
angel
you know it's like we we don't we don't
i don't think the idea of like trying to
conform to the will of
god is just like oh just do do
whatever you want you know no like no
it's like we went like for
for us saying to god do whatever you
want i don't think
i don't think that's how god he i don't
think he god
created us to be like that um
i i think we sure hope not i mean
because
i mean yeah because
so but but i think you can you you we
there's only there's so many there's so
many uh arenas in which we can
kind of we we have to
bump up against this this
god that we that we believe in
and um but a lot of the time it's like
no i don't agree we agree with you i'm
not going to do it like that
and then god is like well how about
how about the the the this and like
i mean like well how about this and he
could be like
well okay but maybe and then the sense
of like
having to give in association it's a
yeah
the the habit of seeing uh obviously
deacon's father sergius
has this great thing about the orthodox
well here all that you say just the this
the the idea that it's forever you know
it has everything oh yeah
well yeah you know um
he's like look can can you imagine how
diverse
a tradition would have to be in order
for it to actually
be for everyone and so that necessarily
means that there are some things that
are for you
and there are some things that are for
other people right that in the tradition
even in the liturgy there are some
things which
you will have trouble attending to or or
that won't necessarily
come to to meet you but that they're
there for them
completely that's fine yeah or
or the marketplace or or that just seem
meaningless or even kind of
wrong or absurd it's like you know
basically
if it seems that way do you fine all
right
yeah but it's an interesting idea for
you the way that people
understand traditional societies like i
said the way the people they portray
uh the middle ages is that this
monolithic thing with the church as
having massive authority and just kind
of imposing its authority on everybody
but if you actually study the middle
ages you realize that it was this
flowering crazy time of like everybody
was all in these guilds and
in these different societies of this
saint and societies of this feast and
they had they had feasts non-stop like
they were constantly celebrating
all these odd particular aspects of
christianity that we don't even can't
understand today
like this idea of celebrating this wound
of christ and having like a
feast about that and so so it was it was
actually
extremely diverse like you said right
because and
but the diversity was possible because
ultimately was in a hierarchy instead of
like you said instead of being this
opposite is that
we we were able to to be able to all fix
our eyes upon something which
transcended
this diversity and therefore the
diversity became acceptable because
yes following price here it's just that
right now this aspect of christ
is the one that's attracting my
attention more than right yeah
the way that you're looking at it yeah
well that's a really interesting point
you just said it's attracting my
attention
right and so the freedom of where to
where to focus your attention where to
direct your attention
was actually given a little bit more i
think i mean maybe this is a
modern fantasy but it was given a little
bit more freely that
that that you you knew that there was
going to be
um that there was going to be demands on
your attention
that you could you could you had agency
over
and you could decide with your community
at whatever
level you know you identified whether it
was your family or
your town or your region munition
that um that you all could pay attention
to
various you know important things at
various important times
and i think right now what we're really
struggling with and it's
i basically i think it's it's validated
by the fact that we call it an attention
economy
that what we're struggling with is the
fact that we don't feel like we have a
lot of agency
um with what we pay attention to but we
do
we just don't feel so we don't feel like
we do partly because
and this is you know the other the other
part of our work is
is this um uh this company we call the
artifact institute that is a
an attempt to talk about that space
outside of worship
and to talk about how how it can be
ideally constructed in order to create
the wealth that we then bring into
worship and whether that's cultural
wealth
or emotional or psychological wealth or
actual
artistic wealth um and that there's a
there's a pulsing there's a sequence of
attention that
is effective in creating a cohesive
culture
and that that sequence is the common
worship
the common work and the common feast and
that those things themselves are kind of
how we perceive
we identify a goal we work towards it
and then we get a little
hit of dopamine because we've attained
it right but that applies to individuals
at in that applies to relationships as
well as individuals
yeah so so this this idea of knowing
where your attention
should go and being free to to direct it
as you will
is i think directly related to actual
like quality of living
um and and we get some satisfaction some
relief from the effort of where to
direct our attention when we worship
we we see other people directing their
attention the same way
and we get reinforcement that this
directing of our attention is
is good and right and then we can be
shaped by
the millennia of of the wisdom the
church has about
about who it is we're paying attention
to exactly because that's kind of a
really big deal
but um what you're saying is so right in
terms of attention because
one of the reasons why we talk about the
passions is because
when we direct our attention towards the
passions we become slaves
we actually don't have freedom we feel
like we have freedom
like when someone falls into some some
some look obsession or whatever in terms
of their attention then
they feel like it's them but at some
point it's not they're
they're being ridden by this passion and
they have to sacrifice to it constantly
whereas like you said the true freedom
of attention
will rather bring us up you know
together right and so
the idea of feasting together or doing
something together a task
as a family or as a group or as a church
or as a community
that is that is actually the freeing up
of attention
from these these these these slave
owners that we have
you know at the bottom of us right right
no that's beautifully put
yeah i mean because we we we're we're in
a time
and i i like what you said a while ago
about we're
we're kind of we're trying to come out
these at this making of art from a place
not of nostalgia but
but actually of kind of gratitude um
i think that's really important because
we we're in a time
now where we actually although we we
kind of like it's a
you know it's it's kind of a rope for us
to say we're just busy
all all the time and we don't have any
free free time
but that's that's nonsense sense
we actually almost all of our time is
free free
free time because for so
many of us and more people every every
year
all over the world what we spend our
time
doing is at some point a thing we chose
to do
um you know that that was not true for
people for most people
past they they didn't have really any
agency
in terms of what they did with the great
majority of their
time they spent a huge majority
of their time just trying to get the
food that they would eat that day today
or
or you know or or just to get under
cover from the elements or get
water or you know or just do the trip
do the parade that they were
born into but now in the modern
age so many of us
choose what we choose what we do with
our time
and if there comes a point where like i
don't think what i'm doing with my time
is meaningful or
good or productive enough or
lucrative enough a lot of us even
relatively poor people
have some freedom to then say i'm gonna
do
do something else um and that and
and then and then even for many of us if
we don't do that other thing
we still have enough to eat we still
have a place to to live you know so
that's
like this is a great this is a great
thing about our modern age um and
so we're we over the last
few years we've been we've started to
become more and more aware of just the
reality that we're
that we're in and how grateful
we can we ought to be um
however this has created a new
problem because every every solution
seems to generate a new problem um
we get good at solving the old problem
we always tend to refer to these as as
good pro
pro problems i will like our pro i
really like our problems
um but our one of our big
problems right now is how do i mean how
do i meaningful
fully spend my time yeah
what do i do with all this with all this
new agency
and new free free free time and some
people just long for no agency
right so yeah people do i wish i would
just be told what to do
because because the reality is that
going to get water
is meaningful yeah of course
one of the difficulties is that as we
are able to free ourselves from those
kinds of tasks
then we're actually low on meaning
unless we have something to replace
that's the problem but it's not but
but i do i don't time for the other i
don't know
yeah you know but so we tried that for a
while yeah we did we did we did three
minutes
we generated our own electricity i don't
know i don't recommend this i mean you
know maybe for some people
people it's a great idea yeah
a lot of work you know but i'm not sure
that the the fact that the back
to the land movement in the state in the
70s and the 80s would have worked
without the uh rush
that a lot of them depend on um
so i mean it's like we i i don't pine
for the alternative but
i do pine for what how do i do
meaningful work
um and so that is in some
way what we're trying to do to answer
with our with our project we that we
call the artifact
institute is is to learn
from the past like to see like
how do people meaningful meaning fully
spend their
time what what is the work that that
that they did how did they
how did they cooperate how did they
overcome their differences
to to kind of to come to a common ideal
and to work to get you to
get together and celebrate to keep to
get together and then on a you know a
more
uh a more um uh then on a smaller scale
gail like just what did they do what
songs
did they sing what dances
did they do how did they set that their
take their
table um what what did they say in their
in their toasts you know it's not
because we i
idealize the past we don't but we can
but we need to learn from it
um and then as we learn from it we try
and we try and recreate it or we try and
we try and reproduce the patterns that
were effective to lose
solutions to common problems yeah and
that's basically what a law
is it's a it's a it's an effective
solution to a
a common problem and it gets called a
law because it's routinely and reliably
effective
not because it's arbitrarily mandated
and and and you have to adhere to the
mandate no it's because of its
effectiveness
so we look at tradition as though it's
it's a it's a set
it's a set of of to a certain extent and
you know
again i don't mean the pejorative sense
a law so but then
once we once we actually enact the law
we need to rely on some
serious social reinforcement so you it
has to be
common it has to be common worship you
have to find
out what other people think if they
value it it's like a market you can't be
a price setter
as an individual you rely on the
reinforcement from as many other people
as possible
that what you say the value is is
actually you know close to what they
think the value is
and so that's where the common part
comes so coaching people through this
process is
kind of what we're trying to try to do
i've been i mean i've been
following your the work you've been
doing on artifact for a while and been
very fascinated and interested in it and
now
but there's a weird irony of the
situation now which is that
is that there is no comment and
and and it's there was no comment before
kobe but right now there seems to be an
active
desire to dismantle the common
uh in in uh you know with good reason i
guess like
yeah it's not like arbitrary right it is
happening nonetheless
and it doesn't seem to be going away
soon at least like where i am
we're not allowed to have people at our
house and we're not allowed to
have any i like church services are 10
people
top maximum right and so and so because
of that
it's it's and it's not going away soon
it's going to be right i mean it's not
going to say it's not
it's not it's not going to go away soon
but it you know
it it might be six months it might be 12
12
12 12 mo
months you know from
now but at some point it will go you
know it's gonna it's gonna change
change well the the nice thing about
this and and
fractals are the most wonderful things
because you can rely on this
shape at whatever level of resolution
you're looking and so
you know it seemed as though what
happened what has happened
um at least in our relatively affluent
culture was that people
have um have turned their
common uh inward and so
what you know we we just we just we just
narrowed our focus
and now our community is the people in
our immediate
physical proximity whether it's our
bubble or our family
you know the people we actually live
with or it's forced
people to basically look at the
community that is their own self
and the the kind of feuding identities
in
in themselves that really frankly we can
ignore them
if we have enough other distracting
things outside of ourselves
but that's the uncomfortable
self-awareness that's come from
quarantine it's like oh lord i don't
want to listen to those voices because
they don't get along well you can have
you can sit down and
force those inner warring voices into a
con into a conflict resolution process
where you come up with a common ideal
you try and articulate what do we
actually agree on me
who doesn't want to do this and me who
does want to do this and then okay
we agree on this one thing cool let's do
it yeah did we do it yay we did it
celebrate us yeah let's have a coffee
yeah i think i think you're right and
and i mean obviously that's why people
would like go to monasteries and stuff
uh but most most people
won't do that it's really they won't do
it on their own like let's just
that's
to kind of to cause that but i also
think one of the things that the pin
dammit has done that we've that we've
we've observed
is it's made people really
see the the value in being together yeah
in a way that we all just took for
granted
with a way that we all just just we to
to took it for branches you don't know
when it's going to happen again
right so that's really important that's
the place where all this comes from and
that's literally the
that's the foundation of what our
worship is supposed to be it's supposed
to be thanksgiving
and and we lose sight of the word that's
what it means right
it's the title of the song you know
um so anything that can help us
in shoes that where we can support each
other into a relationship of gratitude
and sometimes just really actually
objectively looking at
our just the gifts we actually have
the fact that we have a what a report
that we have a refrigerator
who decides to build a smokehouse and
actually preserve their meat
whatever as you know in a in a
traditional non-electric way
they're gonna probably have a deepened
appreciation for that refrigerator yes
they will exactly
and that's that's an argument for
learning these traditional skills but
learning them as
um as art right because it gives you an
appreciation for the technology that we
enjoy
every day and it's also it kind of puts
that technology into a framework where
it can have meaning as opposed to just
being something we consume
take yeah right and so then like in the
same way that like not being able to be
together has made us realize that the
act of simply being together
is like it's like an experience of
worship
and and
faced all i know and work and so it's
all kind of bound up
you know it's the same thing it's like
you know you you do this
this old task and it's something
beautiful and something meaningful
and then and then you then you go and
you open your refrigerator or you
turn on the the lights and you're like
this is this is great this is so awesome
wow thank you god
um you know and the thank you to
mankind for being so smart collectively
um you know that that's that's that's
it's a beautiful thing yeah um you know
we
we we've been liking to say that you
know the the work of our our
artifact is to make america
grateful again um i
it might be too soon it might be too
soon but but but
you know but but you look at where we
are now and you know we have these two
boring sides that are diametrically
opposed
you know and and have legitimate pain
and legit
legitimate you know uh our arguments
on both sides but there's there's so
much resentment
there's so much resist you know and
fine we have things that we can that
we can say our problems you know like be
you know saying
that we need to be grateful is not to
say that there aren't
problems but you cannot you cannot
live in a place of resistance a place of
risk risk determined you will
die in subside yeah
well i think that i think that i find it
amazing to see that you're doing your
little part and we're all trying to do
our little part to to bring some
some gratefulness some magic some light
to the current situation
and so i i will definitely like i'll be
watching because the grammys are wet
like next week is that
yeah yeah and uh march 14th
so we'll all be paying attention thank
you exactly
if we don't win then you can just say
next year no exactly
yeah then because then then the liturgy
will
will i will at least have a chance to be
to be
netted again there's no way to to know
it's you know it's and it's not what i
work for it's i'm not
i i don't compose this i'm already
three pro three or four
projects in from from front of them
that's that's the old stuff
i think we need to celebrate when some
of
the we need to celebrate when those who
are trying to
to create art and create culture that is
vivifying that
is that is kind of bringing us together
and that is celebratory we need to
we need to we need to be happy and to
cast light on that you know so that
because i think you're right like one of
the things that i've been doing and i
think we've all been kind of working
together even if we don't talk to each
other a lot is we really do believe that
there's right now the energy and the
interest to create a cultural movement
that will
that will be a participative cultural
movement and yeah
you know and it's happening it's
happening
from orthodoxy let's say but it has
tendrils that move out
it's it's not just an orthodoxy either i
i it's something i'm seeing
i'm seeing in a lot of in a lot of other
areas that
that we there's there's a sense of a
kind of work where
they're they're there they're they're
they're they're
i think there is a a new a new
died and i think i i think orthodoxy has
a part to play
in this but um but i think it's really
important that it comes from a place of
gratitude and from a positive
vision of what we can build
you know because like i cuz like you
know because there's this big the
split now of the rural and the urban de
[ __ ] fight and uh and we we spent a lot
of time over the last
20 years in small town america and in
rural world
and in rural areas you know and you can
absolutely see
the sense of meaninglessness and and the
pain and the sense of like
the world has passed you by and you've
been forgotten
and and the and the uh and the in the
in the and the and the elites and the
billions
nairas are off they're doing their their
their thing and they've
they've forgotten us but
you know and so you just you can
absolutely see how that
that would inspire resentment um
but you know one of the things it sounds
really strange and really easy to say
to that day but i think what a lot of
people pined for about the past is the
sense
is those is the times that they imagine
that they're that their small town was
was actually a
beautiful place to be and the buildings
were
were overwhelming contained and they
could go to
to the county
fair or to the town dance or
go listen to to the town
band or have a have a have a party to
get together
or go go to go to church to get to get
to get together all of these things are
in since part of
they're actually an artistic
nobody is actually stopping us from
being able to do these
things yeah you know i mean
you know of course yeah right in general
now but it's gonna
change it's gonna you know so but
but it's like we could we could maintain
our small towns we we have a lot of free
time and we have more disposable
in in income than that than we realized
we could start a town fan
we could have a town dance we could go
and talk to our
to the people next to the people
next to the door and we would probably
find that we actually had a lot in
common
you know and it's like why don't we
why don't we do these things well you
know it's it's
the thing that's getting in the way of
it is
is mis mistrust of the other
and resentment uh you know but if you
sense and to be fair if you take
jonathan's perspective
a little anxiety about doing it wrong
well that's true too yeah there's that
and i i refer to you because because i
hear the anxiety
oh i don't know how i don't about doing
music music
so in order to do that you need a guide
and there's the hierarchical structure
again
you just need the person who can walk
you through so you don't fall in a
pothole
and then you get to enjoy it yeah and
you can lean on them a little bit
yeah yeah well i i really i celebrate
the things you're doing and
i just need them to be in french soon so
that i can
so that i can i can uh engage with them
in a more
in my actual surroundings but well then
then fairness yeah okay
all right noticed let's uh let's
yeah let's figure it out all right so i
will so
i will i would like i said i'll be
paying attention to the upcoming
uh awards and i'm just really happy that
you're
that you're in the church that you guys
are being so
so active and even the videos you're
posting about your family and
kind of these moments together i think
it's very valuable to
help people see what it can be like to
just
have a good time together because that's
something that it seems
difficult for us to do you know today
because of everything that's going on so
i appreciate that as well so thanks for
thanks for coming on and talking to me
today it's such a pleasure
awesome